I want to admit something to you
yesterday or that I did yesterday all
right I saw the interview good for you I
wish I had I I I'm going to watch it
today later on YouTube I think and it
succeeded in doing one thing I gave my
credit card to Google Play that was what
the interview that was what the
interview did for me I think there's a
lot of things that this whole experience
is loosening up look at all these people
going to Independent theaters I bet most
of them never have even been to an
independent theater thank God we have
independent theaters the best thing that
happened to the Almo Draft House ever I
mean I feel like Sony has handled this
so poorly from the start and the Alamo
Draft House has handled this beautifully
true you know once Sony pulled the movie
this was still a week ago uh the Draft
House announced this is a place by the
way in a couple cities in America where
you can drink beer eat dinner and watch
movies the chain of independent theaters
essentially amazing and we are going to
be speaking to somebody from the Alam
draft that was coming up later on in the
show uh I also got to watch the
interview I streamed it on Christmas Eve
on YouTube like you it was the first
time I had ever given my credit card
over to Google or Google play so I think
it was a big win for them but I have to
say Brandon I really thought it was a
horrific use of my six bucks it was I
liked it you liked it yeah I really
liked it listen it's silly it's absurd
it's low bar it's it's what your kids
might call potty humor but it kind of
works Seth Rogan and James Falco really
do have chemistry I enjoy I mean they've
had chemistry since the late '90s but I
mean I so I enjoyed it but I think my
expectations were too high it was
supposed to be amazing this sort of Act
of Civil Disobedience of watching the
movie but the Act was supposed to be
amazing exactly James Franco and Seth
Rogan were going to be AB I think for me
the best way to put it is that it was a
movie that I would have enjoyed on a
flight at some point I would have had it
not been for last night I would have
reserved it for a flight how do you feel
about the exploding head of Kim Jong-un
was that justified was that necessary
giving away the pl well that's been
given away quite pretty sure we know
that who dies in the end actually I I
wasn't sure he was going to die there
was some released there was some
released footage yeah I thought that was
an amazing moment it turns out that it
wasn't just Mindless Gore it was
scripted into the movie as part of a
Katy Perry song I really thought that
they handled that moment gorgeously I
love that wow working in the Katie here
listen I really liked it about streaming
on five for $5.99 was pretty good uh and
I re I'm going to go out there and
recommend it and and I think you know
Sony's Network went down again when they
tried to stream it Sony just is not in
the business of hardening a network and
streaming a lot of videos Google of
course is they went fine son's clearly
not in the business of hardening that
works yes